لقد سمعت كلمة الأيورفيدا
منذ أن كنت طفلاً لأنه على الرغم من أن
أياً من والديّ لا يعملان كأطباء ،
إلا أنهما مارسان أشكالًا من الأيورفيدا
والتي تعني أساسًا علم
الحياة ، فهي واحدة من أقدم
الممارسات الصحية في أي مكان في العالم ، فكيف
يحدث ذلك؟  إنها الثانية ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
هذا يبدو وكأنك تعني العمل
بالطعام ، فإن نظام الأيورفيدا الغذائي
رائع حقًا بالنسبة لي ، لذا فإن أمي مرة أخرى ،
وهي ليست طبيبة على الرغم من أنها مهندسة
منظمة للغاية ،
سيكون لديها كل توابلها في
الخزانة وتقريباً  بالنسبة لهم
كممارس رعاية صحية ، فإنهم ينظرون
إلى تلك التوابل المختلفة لأغراض مختلفة
، على سبيل المثال الزنجبيل
جيد جدًا للهضم
جيد جدًا لاضطراب المعدة ، يمكن للقرفة في
الواقع أن تزيد من الدورة الدموية ،
لقد حددوا بعض الأطعمة التي
اكتشفوا وظائف تلك الأطعمة
مثل أي نوع  من الوظيفة التي
يقدمونها في الجسم ثم تناولوا
الأطعمة التي لها وظائف مختلفة
ووضعوها معًا وصنعوها  إد
النظام الغذائي الأيورفيدا عن طريق طهي طبق يسمى الطير ،
إنه مصنوع من جميع أنواع الخضروات الطازجة الجميلة
عندما ننظر إلى العناصر الغذائية
التي نحتاجها إلى الفيتامينات ، والأشياء
التي يحتاجها جسمنا ، نعلم جيدًا
أنه يمكننا الحصول عليها من الطبيعة ، لذلك إذا
كنت تأكل  لون قوس قزح سبعة
أطعمة ملونة مختلفة ، ثم
ستحصل على جميع العناصر الغذائية التي تحتاجها ،
إنه أمر سحري للغاية ، لا نفكر في
الطعام بهذه الطريقة ، ولكن إذا ذهبت ومارست
الطب الهندي القديم أو عشت
أسلوب الحياة هذا ، فهذا بالضبط ما يفكرون فيه
لذا فإن الشيء الرائع الآن هو
أن نرى علم الأيورفيدا يبدأ
في الظهور في المقدمة